بينما يظهر لنا الناشط السياسي الروسي الذي تحول إلى
مخبر fsb حول
مركز اللاجئين الهولندي حيث يسعى الآن للحصول على
اللجوء ،
كل ما أريده في المستقبل هو
حياة طبيعية إيجابية ، كما يقول
بدون المزيد من هذه المغامرات
[موسيقى]
كان ناشطًا معارضًا شابًا
استحوذ ميخائيل الذي شوهد هنا في
احتجاج مناهض للحكومة في روسيا
على انتباه جهاز أمن الكرملين ، ولا بد
أن
عمله الأخير في أليكسي نافالني
روسيا ، أبرز زعيم معارضة مسجون في روسيا ،
جعله
ذا قيمة خاصة ،
لكنه كان مستهدفًا في الأصل ليتم
تحويله كما أخبرني  بتهديدات FSB
كانوا يعلمون أنني كنت أتجنب
الخدمة العسكرية وأعطوني خيارًا بسيطًا
إما التعاون معهم أو الذهاب إلى
السجن لسنوات في
الأساس ، لقد تعرضت للتهديد
وكطالب يبلغ من العمر 19 عامًا خائفًا جدًا ،
هناك الكثير من القصص حتى مقاطع الفيديو
لأشخاص  إساءة المعاملة في السجن حتى
التفكير في هذا أمر مخيف أنك كنت
تعمل مع navalny ، فهناك صور
لك تعمل عن كثب  معه
ما نوع المعلومات
التي قدمتها لـ fsb عنه ،
لم أكن صديقه المقرب ، لذا لم أتمكن من
إعطائهم معلومات خاصة
عنه ، كنت أعمل للتو في مكتب إقليمي ،
لذلك كانوا مهتمين أكثر
عندما كنا نخطط لذلك  عقد اجتماعات
أو احتجاجات وبالطبع ما هو نوع
التحقيقات التي كنا
نجريها حتى أننا تعاونا في بعض هذه
التحقيقات
بعد أي احتجاج إعلامي ، فإن مكتب الأمن الفيدرالي قد
يسجن أو يحمي مسؤولًا معينًا
، بالإضافة إلى مراقبة
النشطاء داخل البلاد.
يبدو أيضًا أن الأجهزة
الأمنية كثفت من مراقبتها
للروس الذين يعيشون في الخارج ، يقول ميخائيل إن مكتب الأمن
الفيدرالي أخرجه من روسيا
وأرسله إلى جمهورية جورجيا السوفيتية السابقة
للتسلل إلى
الجالية المغتربة المتزايدة هناك الهاربين من
القمع في الداخل
جنبًا إلى جنب مع شبكة أخرى من مكتب الأمن الفيدرالي.
المخبرين موجودون
بالفعل
كمخبرين مثل
ناشط سياسي شاب آخر
يقول إن FSB يمثل تهديدًا أيضًا  أدخله
السجن
ما لم يرسل تقارير مفصلة من
جورجيا وما
كان يفكر فيه
بعض المعارضين الروس تحديدًا بشأن حرب أوكرانيا التي اندلعت
في فبراير من هذا العام والتي أجبرت العديد من
منتقدي الكرملين إلى المنفى
وعمليات المخبرين في مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الذي
يخبرني
بأن ما يقوله ذلك.  إليكم
بشأن المخاوف في موسكو بشأن
ما يمكن أن يحدث
في المستقبل ، ما الذي يخافونه
منا نحن الخدمات الخاصة الروسية
تدرك جيدًا تاريخنا عندما
يظهر مجتمع مهاجرين روسيين ضخم في
الخارج حيث يتحدث الناس بحرية مع بعضهم
البعض ويعملون في المشاريع  ساعدوا معًا
اللاجئين الأوكرانيين
وخلقوا روسيا صغيرة في الخارج لا
تخضع لسيطرة FSB ، فهم يخشون
أن يعيد التاريخ نفسه في عام 1917 ،
جاء لينين إلى موسكو وبدأ ثورة روسية
وهم مرعوبون من
أن يتعرض النظام للتهديد مرة أخرى من قبل
الحرب
كانت معارضتهم للحرب على حد سواء
سيفيرلاد وميخائيل يقولان أخيرًا ملزمة
د عليهم أن يديروا
ظهورهم لمعالجي fsb ، ميخائيل حتى ظهر
على التلفزيون الجورجي يوبخ
النظام الروسي الذي تجسس من أجله ، قمت
بإرسال رسالة نصية إلى رجال fsb وأخبرتهم
أنهم بدأوا هذه الحرب بأنها كانت
مروعة ، لقد رأيت كل الصور على الإنترنت و
لقد قلبوا العالم رأساً على عقب
لأنني لم أشعر فقط بالكراهية تجاه
الحكومة الروسية ولكن تجاه نفسي
لأنني أعمل معهم طوال هذه السنوات ،
إنه كراهية ذاتية وشعور عميق
بالذنب بسبب الأكاذيب والخيانات التي يقول
إنه أجبر على فعلها.
ماثيو فرصة سي إن إن أمستردام